crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab fish I'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every to see you
already know though Orion's egg the
soccer star JUCO above ground crew goes
better than most Jay Larson
self-diagnosed go download this week
last week here we go again [ __ ] the crab
feast
oh yeah
welcome back to the crab feast y'all
another Tuesday tickle oh crap fees for
that an oh I rattled up inside my chest
we were going at the I mean we were just
man it was hard but it was good job
[ __ ] talking Jay Larson it to be here
sickle-cell good FISA nation Jay Larson
here Jay Larson call me calm Jay Larson
calm and that's a new website dealer
scale RC common jailers I'm doing a new
co-production with common we got new
album coming out it's pretty basic Jay
Lawson comedy and all social media a
couple things this saturday night i'll
be at the ice house at nine thirty p.m.
the third of May ryan i will be at the
comedy store with our friends of the
crappy stand-up show and then on the
21st i'll be in nashville at zanies
doing the LOL tubidy show will be in
Bridgetown very excited two weekends
after that the second third and fourth
and the 28th of May I'll be headlining
the Westside comedy theater here in
Santa Monica so that's something to
check out and then I've been saying it
for a minute two ways out but i'll be in
dublin the 27 the 28th 29th 30th of july
and london after that but I don't have
the location for that just yet sickle
cell you know what I'm just gonna say
thank you to everybody out there I
really appreciate the Feaster's I get a
lot of emails and we do we do we
absolutely do so all I'm going to do is
just tell you about the show's Jay
mentioned comedy storm a third we have
Michael Kosta we have steven is easy
bryan callen Ron Funches a possible
special for us and maybe we're not going
to confirm they're always going to be
special shows so that's a sick line a
plus you're at the comedy store in every
show in there is sick we also have a
live crab feast podcast the Hollywood
improv on May seventeenth as Jay
mentioned bridgetown the live podcast is
on the fourth and thank you guys thank
you for everything you do yes Jason I do
want to say thank you too for everyone
that out there that to watch the
invitation and hit me up about it so
many crab feast fans you guys are the
best I appreciate you supporting
and so what I saw one uh one guy said
that the iTunes page with all the [ __ ]
the crappy comments they were gonna
think like oh really old but yeah but
that's what's amazing about you guys is
that you know it's it's a whole other
thing you took the time and I appreciate
it and uh you guys are the best you are
the best and I want to go into this yeah
man okay ah some special sponsors is
because we got a special day around the
corner as you guys know may 8th is
Mother's Day forget do you love your
mom's right not so much Jay I do but
let's I'm gonna say some every mom is
unique and every mom wants something
special every wife this isn't just
mothers days like you know your monster
or you Wyatt your sister neighbors in
Contra you're lucky from boss whatever
um mother's Day is just around the
corner so a great way to show your mom
or your wife you're on tour your
grandmother how you appreciate her
shari's berries let me tell you
something every time we do campaign with
them they send over a box of these
things here and every time I come home
Kate looks at me like a nine-year-old
kid in college she goes can I eat those
strawberries and I'm like yeah go ahead
get Adam and then she'll take off the
light you know there's everything
there's white chocolate is milk choc
this dark chocolate this swirls dis
little tiny crunch swore off let's which
he gives to read she's given read these
little tiny and there's not crunched
this is just ridiculous they're so
awesome and every single time of their
huge there there are huge i Yale uh
reads babysitter she were like hey you
want to get at those strawberry she's
like it's okay we're like yeah crush
those things it's a cold three out of a
person a napkin already here's the deal
get cherries berries freshly dipped
strawberry starting at nineteen ninety
nine plus shipping or you can double up
those berries for just ten dollars more
this is exclusive for our listeners if
you go to Barry's calm berr IES calm
click on the microphone on the top right
corner and type in crab milk chocolate
white chocolate we talked about a huge
fresh delicious here's the best thing
you picked a delivery date you want and
it's guaranteed so you can go on today
and have it delivered the day before eat
chocolate covered fruit man come right
to your door
great it's unbelievable and what I'm
saying is don't sleep you know I mean go
to visit berries calm berr IES calm
click on the microphone top right corner
type in our code crab and boom mother's
day is going to be a woman who had a
child in your life deserves it odd happy
life happy life from a happy wife the
opposite or mom whatever it is I'll tell
you who we are very stoked to have back
touch a modern is back touch of modern
if you're ready to upgrade your
lifestyle and leave boring behind all
while getting the best prices on the web
touch of modern calm has all the latest
trends across fashion tech and de coeur
that's where I said a core with the best
prices anywhere actually this would be a
good place for to get mom a gift to it's
not just you don't think just four guys
here touch of modern calm go there now
they correct connect you directly with
top designers they have timeless and
unique products all the best prices
online anywhere guaranteed I i still i
go on daily and look and that's the
other thing if you don't get it it's
gone you know you want to get mom that
sexy home decor they have it man the
thing that's what I love but we don't
know with the your mom's into 60
stepping it up over there yeah man they
also have men's fashion accessories
sleek iphone cases and accessories
eye-catching new and vintage watches
there are Rolexes on there I've seen
them my own eyes because I watch them
all the time with nodes loads of new
sales literally launching every day
touch of modern calms the one website to
discover and improve your lifestyle and
a single click right now our listeners
can get immediate access to these deals
when you sign up a touch of modern calm
that's touch of modern calm do it today
because tomorrow it'll be different
that's how life rolls in the fast lane a
lot of options here one more for you
from Mother's Day here's the deal it's
Mother's Day I couldn't send my mom
chocolate strawberries you know I mean
because that's just not my mom she like
oh this is great wait and then give them
to somebody who would love them yes what
I need to give my mom is flowers that's
what my mom's gonna love ya if you got a
bomb out there my mom is a fly you sent
her flowers Jason these flowers are
wonderful that's my mom she's gonna have
them and we've both gotten flowers from
for every time every single time from
plovar and how long do they last it I
honestly got almost two weeks they
they're guaranteed for seven days but
they've way
always gonna do it right you got Dora
it's what I'm underwater you're an angle
got them cut yellow sugar a little food
and they give you the thingy they give
me the back yet mom 100 blooms with a
free glass vase for 1999 plus shipping
and handling or make your day extra
special upgrade to a premium days and
add gourmet chocolates for just 999 see
this is where then that's my mom's gonna
be then that's where i can send the
chock right I flower and I chocolate
boom go to proflowers.com today and use
our code crab proflowers takes the
guesswork out of sending mom grandma or
wife the perfect Mother's Day gift you
don't to be the guy stuck at Mother's
day without doing something just get on
it or the or the lady can't beat the
price inconvenience proflowers takes
care of all the details proflowers
guaranteed to be fresh and beautiful or
at least seven days your money back
choose to live or your money back take
your goddamn money unbelievable choose
the delivery date you want it's
guaranteed it's a no-brainer the only
way to get a hundred blooms in a free
glass vase target 1999 visit
proflowers.com click the blue microphone
in the top right corner and type in our
code crab that's proflowers.com click on
the microphone type in crab remember
mother's day is next week order today
this offer expires friday at midnight
speaking of moms who and she's not gonna
expire anytime soon she can go go go go
go we're stoked stoked to have her back
because it's always an amazing time lazy
and welcome back to the crab feast key
result of a welcome clap for myself you
should clap yeah you tell everybody that
we don't tip him off but if you're doing
it you're feeling it I'm feeling it I'm
good to have you back thanks guys thanks
for having me I like it I like a new
space thanks so much Oh different tune
with mics are wrong wrong raises I feel
like it could use a poster I don't know
much we just moved in just got a 20 days
ago we got this you're the banner you've
had 19 days to get a poster at least
like a cat like it's Friday we have we
have them I actually want to tell you I
haven't pulled out I'm gonna get you a
crab feast poster yeah man we're gonna
frame him up and put him up i got the
cloud if I brought you in a calendar a
kitty be nice in a tree hang in there
it's almost friday would you guys put it
up ya que tu in a tree i'm gonna bring
one do the truth um thank
you again for being here or very excited
to have you back and so we just want to
get rolling with you as always so will
you please before we start just tell
them everything you want to know yeah um
I'm a B+ blood type are you rare that
the best rare it's the best no no it's
not what I am is the bet no there's one
that like Oh paddle with everything yeah
I'm oh no ma'am a rare kind of Scylla
allergic to penicillin Oh worst best
drug i've ever had okay good i am on the
twitter i'm on at kira comedy oh I just
started Instagram welcome look I same
bust your balls i'm such a late day like
such an idiot but i did really just
start that it's also cured comedy and
Facebook and all that and my websites
kira comedy and I have a special coming
out yes you do fine it really is a year
later I shot it last Mother's Day yeah
but these think a long time it's it's
prepping to get the material and it's
getting it polished and it's getting the
venue getting the money shooting it
probably shooting it from what I've
heard yes exact day you were right Oh
kid we had to stop down because we ran
out of money I mean stop down we at we
were like editing you know nearly 30
minutes in the middle of a joke to be
continued we had to stop we had to stop
when we were editing doing like the
final you know all the edits you're like
I feel like this is like the the same
story that IBM had we launched we got a
couple computers out then we had to get
money well I think so I actually was
pregnant when I did your podcast for the
first time December but you didn't tell
us I didn't that's what I was like you
told us later we did the math or like so
well she didn't tell the dad at that
point right figure that out but I was
like they're gonna know I'm pregnant cuz
these TIG ol bitties hey when they were
insane and I was leaving the next day
for Israel so I flew to Israel um very
nauseous and just you feel just
disgusting and I was sooo next to maz
jobrani just a crazy coincidence for
real for reals and he was flying to a
remember now someone is easier and and
we were and they were they were flying
us business class and we were sitting
next to each other no no come on because
Maz Jobrani flies business class but our
tickets you even ready boomstick Maz
Jobrani flies business class that is a
t-shirt and I'm gonna make it and sell
it out of my job salute birch but he and
I were sitting just crazy coincidence we
were sit next to each other and um I for
sure thought we're gonna die because it
was the worst flight I have ever been on
whatever just the turbulence was insane
the the most insane term and he and I
look to each other we're like okay so
there's we might die we might die but
it's cool we're together like we had
come how I mean talk about the two most
positive of people can ever be with for
real too yeah but also I'd be a little
worried that the fact that we just got
placed together on this complete
randomness right this might be it and
you're just here to help comfort each
other yeah 22 Brown large nose people
they were like this is the flight for
you you guys I've never I've never been
more terrified and nauseous just from
being pregnant right and then nauseous
from being like when the file tab the
turbulence like was it shaky or drop II
it was both oh it was up down left right
I was they almost like the entire first
two hours Jesus I'd rather the first to
the last well yeah but the last chilly
should get some drinks back and you know
i mean like here we were the the flight
attendants so i know it's bad when a
flight attendant goes huh that's
happened twice when they abandon the
drink cart I'm just gonna they just like
home run into the bed where is she she's
buckled up watch he wasn't up there oh
it was awful why does she have a
parachute on everyone no Wi-Fi parachute
god she's she's out oh is it all the
time
frightening so anyways that's last time
I was on the show and I was pregnant
then but and the both you I mean were
you having flat because now that i have
kids the last time I flew there was
turbulence and I I'm usually I used to
be before kids I'm like if it's my time
it's my time go ahead right now my god
do I want to see them grow through the
like I don't know if I want to chance it
now I just knew that if it went down to
his name would be in the paper my bike
Oh another comedian probably his feature
separate that's right you two would have
been linked together as like these two
comedians have died together in a tragic
plane crash on their way to a venue and
people will be like where the [ __ ] was
try to reach out with that you know some
open my car black when can we get that
yeah is that whatever their whatever
they were making I'll do it half for
afternoon yeah so anyways I don't know
why I got a whole story but that's last
I was on so I'd already knew that I was
going to shoot my special um but then I
got pregnant so that my special turned
into me being pregnant in my special I
don't revisit the point that's the plan
to shoot it one of my favorite and least
favorite questions of all time were you
guys trying to get pregnant like I love
asking people that cuz you're basically
why you're asking someone your basement
like how regularly were you guys back
like that's what you're saying you know
i mean i know its nature but it's like
at the same time you're just like so you
guys banging on the reg or what was
going on so it's this is kind of a sad
story because we we uh uh don't make it
say it's bad sad it's just gonna be sad
you read alright so i had a birthday and
on my birthday I don't know where I I
started to miss my brother who has
passed away uh-huh and so I don't know I
very rarely cry about him it's so rare
I'm just like I'm like whenever it's
cool like I just had it very sweet very
nice yeah I know but at some point you
know Mom jumping off you right at some
point you got to be like you know brush
it off right wait walk it off so but at
for some reason I was like having a
birthday and I don't know why and I just
lost it we were like on our couch our
bathroom
was being remodeled in our house is like
a master bedroom with the bathroom
that's kind of part of the room how much
can she's throwing a day she's been well
business class remodeling a bathroom as
a master bed and maz jobrani was
actually remodeling he does a favor for
me now and then and so we couldn't sleep
in our bedroom because they're just too
dusty so we're sleeping on the couch for
months until our bathroom is done and so
we're on the couch and and I just start
balling and he's like what's wrong with
you and I was like I just feel bad
because our older son was three at the
time I was like he's not gonna have a
sibling and I just started missing my
brother and I guess my husband just gave
me a pity [ __ ] shut up let me talk about
delayed making someone feel better
listen you feel great about 10 months
you miss your brother love of a dick I
don't know so thank you ever come to our
house just know we we did on the couch a
lot bill the same couch same couch magic
sorry I'm just doing a couch though
writer that weird that you don't you
don't you did whatever you want to do it
no but I'm saying like and then you have
company over it's just like that's what
we did it I you soon our bodies couch I
stood on this problem [ __ ] on right I
just that's why I go in if it's not it's
kind of weird almost our staircase by
the way is also a nice place yeah it's
fun great angles it's fun yeah you make
circles your brother they're always bag
me from behind every what what's so
great about like that was the answer to
your question is yes it was planned we
did it was going so fast I was planned
on one night ik it was a very emotional
evening I gave our kid the the pregnancy
test I peed on a pregnancy test right
and I knew my husband was coming home
from work and so I gave my kid i might
go when daddy comes home you give him
this and so he walks over and goes daddy
look and my husband looks at it the
first thing out of his mouth I'm getting
snipped it wasn't like yay we did he was
like I'm getting snipped yeah meanwhile
he's crazy about her Blake her crazy
like Gila he's so good he's so good he's
a really good daddy
good Zoe so you shot the special so yeah
so I just continued with my planning i
started in September right I saw you
guys december two thousand fourteen i
already started planning you know
shooting and producing and looking for a
venue and all the stuff we didn't think
was gonna happen I didn't either and
then and then I had an investor and that
guy pulled out and then I had to I said
you guys I put out I saw her eyes face
and then so I had a crowd fund which I
had never done before ever rafi
supported I I appreciate mode guys
because it was it's expensive it's
expensive to shoot there and so I had
done Adam crew I'm dropping I'm scan me
let's just go look i I'm I'm blessed
hashtag blessed gosh dang i had done
Adam curls podcast and he goes look I'm
gonna give you some advice if you
crowdfund the perks that you give people
have to be really insane and also
personal to you so like he's crowdfunded
to his movies and you know if someone
donates like thirty thousand dollars
then they you know their EP and they
come to his house they have dinner and
they go to the premiere and they you
know they all take a bath or whatever
it's like I do something fancy so I
thought okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna
think of something really good so for
twenty five thousand dollars if you
contributed to my crowdfunding we were
gonna let you cut the cord ah we donated
24 grams just sure love to cut the cord
nobody bit on that one oh right not one
person Butler maybe I was not even like
a can I put a layaway nothing yeah but
for 20,000 we said you can help us name
the child yeah hmm and we got one you
did yes we want to use with their
suggestion Tyrone you you're so cool oh
yeah they were it was they were like
whatever you want but they but we opened
it up we're like no give us you know you
can suggestions wow I would never let
that funny why not a comic who's
desperate for money to tell her dick
jokes to the world sure to the world to
the world whoever's gonna watch it on
what's gonna be certainly in Russia at
least I love you it will be it will be
in Russia um because we're gonna be
international right now may second it'll
be on baby
second they say second 16 in case you're
listening to this next week next week
next yes next yeah for two weeks what
does I don't know who know ya next
Monday I don't know the math um I don't
have calendars I'm just fluid you know
yes like yoga poses that's all I had to
I tell time when I do a warrior 2 i'm
like in which ways the Sun hitting where
is this so may second amazon and like
all them everywhere they're streaming
you know so it's gonna be everywhere
itunes amazon go play dish network video
on demand great exhaust all who do is a
thing I don't know voodoo was a thing it
is if you believe in it hulu all the
places that's great yeah so grats ohm a
second what's the name of it you did
this to me literally girl can't tell you
what that was that your response so I'm
getting sniped ah that is a bit yes but
yes I don't want him to get sniped I
think that's a little accessory on it
yet no he has not she's eight months old
I think that's extreme I don't know
their we didn't get pregnant until we
decided to get pregnant two times we
decided two times we got pregnant and
I've never ever the thing is though they
getting snipped it just turns into any
time anywhere anytime anywhere girl you
look at anything a non-union viagra
commercial you know it are like and now
he's ready and they're slow dancing I
don't think it's I think it's extreme
would you do it I'd consider it really
yeah we'll consider it I don't know if
what i need it i think i'm gonna do it
what are you are yeah yeah just cuz I
don't you know I it's you know you
paying birth do you do birth control no
see birth control you're dropping like
90 bucks a month so then you're looking
over course the next 10 years if you
taking birth control that's 10 G's if
you pull out you drop a 90 sperm a month
so that's not bad what's up girl just
say anymore you know it's whatever cuz I
don't we definitely makes one active
[ __ ] to get up and they're not [ __ ]
it all up no no no we're not gonna have
kids again but we also haven't I don't
know I just feel is it bad that I'm like
no you probably won't have another kid
I'm sure that won't happen here what if
you had emotional and then you miss your
brothers like
son that was on the crab feast I was
actually pregnant and I knew it and I
don't want to tell you guys we did that
whole story we're just gonna be like no
whammies no whammies no whammies stop
and we're just gonna that's how we're
gonna have sex like Amazon Amazon is
gonna come to you like Kira this
specialist doing great guilt you're
gonna have to have another baby you're
gonna you know it's what happens you're
gonna break exactly and you're gonna
have twins and you're gonna be like what
forbid yeah no I don't know how you're
doing right now with two little ones I
am losing my [ __ ] mind yeah I know
did you have this moment at all when you
realize when the second one came out
like you know I have to teach another
person everything yeah well everything I
just look at her and I'm just like a lot
[ __ ] you don't know anything yeah at
least he knows stuff yeah but you know
it's it's just whatever I said a kto day
I'm like you realize it's gonna be like
we got another solid three years three
years of diapers right now you know I
mean it's just crazy but whatever it is
what it is you know we uh we made our
bed Noah lion it that's what we tell her
every day your family bed do you guys
I'm sleep with you know okay good yeah
it's great it's just what everyone
parents differently yes I'm sure your
kids not clingy you know I mean no big
deal everyone does it differently you
know I mean come on you really want to
get into like parenting right now ah no
but yes but no no we don't have to but
don't do a family bad i think that's
kind of we read is like super
independent like he won't even snuggle
with you on the couch like i'ma comin
you want to read he's like me I sit here
and like you like you don't wanna like
snuggling know and then my friend's son
is like snuggle town and he sleeps in
the bed with him and like and I'm like
I'm it i wish that you know if we had
done that maybe he'd snuggle more and do
all those things he just does he's not
into it he just likes to do is only
getting super independent on his own so
you know there's like yeah I know no I
think it's amazing but it still there's
a plus and a minus to every situation I
I couldn't even sleep with our
five-year-old this [ __ ] maniac does
not sleep like a human being yeah he
doesn't sleep like a he's like like one
of those what are those dolls that you
who do hey knock down and it could be
back up no just the one the clown was
like the fur [ __ ] weeble wobble we're
like lie down and they're just legs up
and we're like lie down arms fling him
he's just
constantly he like had me in a bowling
ball grip the other night when he curled
it but they just hands and fingers
everywhere he's just aggressive man yeah
so we can't sleep with them anyway so
yeah um I'll something about the special
the shooting of it ah for people that
are gonna watch it i hope that you do
may second on amazon I'm just pushing
the Amazon push me what everyone do this
is like a baby ah push through the lobby
just so everyone's clear through the
lobby love not not the sunroof um I the
whole entire time when I didn't realize
when you're pregnant you have to pee a
lot as you guys both know dealing with
pregnant chicks oh maybe I'm pregnant oh
you people like to use a lot yeah you
might want to get that checked out yeah
is it burning nope okay okay no you're
right just overworked in my bladder just
yeah that bladder doing push-ups
overworking of it there do it's like
jumping rope and chili salsa I was
pissing myself the entire time I was on
stage shut your babies like a marathon
ago my golly Peters the entire time so
for people watching my son showing your
special the entire tell how many times
all the time but you may all time no
listen on the stage is it on the stage
maybe hey every time he is stage drama I
didn't look down the entire look at me
when I'm talking right in your eyes the
entire time like every time you walk
you're just the pila Ryan yes [ __ ]
herself twice I didn't know I just
thought little Burt came out but
different no it was the entire time how
many months pregnant were you up to
those seven and a half so your kiddos
because I drink a lot of water cuz i
wanted to stay hydrated and then didn't
even think like a dummy because of my
second time having it be i know i should
know better didn't go to the bathroom at
first because i just was too busy i
produce the entire thing from top to
bottom when your talent on a special you
shall the theater they're like great
here's hair and makeup here have to
underwater go on stage you're done then
you leave and you get in your car and
then everyone wraps out i was there at
ten a.m.
to set up to shoot at eight yeah it's a
long day so I'm just I just wasn't and a
full bladder and a full belly full of
baby and I just the entire time so
that's just a little inside so I'm on
stage you are in light grey pants sand
courts skorts listen work what were you
really wearing black pants and were you
gonna wear that regardless yes I'm
saying had you had you honestly picked
oh it would have done we're done it's a
wrap it really was a rack if you want
khaki to be continued really yeah as I
see because this is the first time that
happened to you right or had you been
this happening throughout the seven and
a half months I'm asking no there's
nothing like no I mean look when you
when I sneeze little or walk upstairs
order link you're down the creepy little
no oh you're not like PPP but I the
entire time stay she carries a big old
hey I do it was horrendous home this
because just one okay she's gonna get in
the pocket right you just want to be in
the moment and you can't because L the
audience no but other [ __ ] went down so
i'll tell you guys what everything that
happened i think the new hat I mean it
should be a subtitle for your album is
imposed it is oh yeah hopefully I mean
as unless I mean its audience it was I
feel like there's a campaign opportunity
here with what does it suave don't ever
let him see you sweat yeah don't I let
me to be hands it depends yeah whooping
I mean I I don't even know um over this
[ __ ] dr. Keegan is amor it doesn't do
anything because I have under key he's
the one that invented the Kegel what's
the Kegel the vagina exercising he just
leaves him squeeze it so that he but I
keep it nice and tight did your wife
have him through the lobby have what
through the lobby babies so her vagina
oh no sunroof a sunroof you okay so it's
fine she's okay yeah Cara don't you spit
it off when you guys are [ __ ] on your
couch it's okay fine everything is fine
I just like to look at Jay Larson so
that i can imagine weird thing is
they're looking at pictures of your
brother that's what's really where it's
while there I would say they are they
are I don't know what it is it just gets
you in the mood um I just love Jay
Larson's looks it's like it's like what
every father whose kid goes into stand
up that's how he looks like this is what
you chose you couldn't focus more in
school good none any good made any
better choices do people ask you what
like what if your children want to stand
up to people to ask you that yes what do
you say no you're gonna tell her no I
mean I would encourage her to do
something else in the entertainment
industry if she wants to be in the
entertainment industry they have you
know a little more maybe a union
guaranteed type [ __ ] maybe some set
salaries and you know sort those sorts
of mysteries they don't sure everything
you work on her sort of taken away so
you'd rather her work in the audio
department yeah she could mix she could
mix but no she can do whatever she wants
to do but I just think like you know
well she could be a DP or a director you
know at least they have unions and
they're protected you know they have
guilt I mean Gil come on I don't well I
just stand up guild are you in right now
I'm in the SCC fortunate 50 local will
get yo what's your stand of you did the
local eight dollars at the improv that's
what I'm oh my god when they give you
the eight dollars of the improv it's
like are you know I'm like let's just
give it to him come on I mean don't why
are you even can you pull it together
and just give me someone at the end of
the year and I'll be like Oh 48 bucks
thank you like I can't take the eight
dollars you'll get more spots got a
special coming out on Amazon talking
about 80 anyways I was pissing myself
either that's amazing it really is let
me tell you you're so let me tell you
what happened during this [ __ ]
special which I am very proud of and I
love but it's so hard like you did an
hour an hour hearing your self it the
whole time have I made myself clear yeah
our wedding was a disaster my plans are
to know no but I feel like I attract
disasters I don't know why and somehow
as you can handle it maybe because our
wedding was absolutely what you see
in a movie knowing like everything
[ __ ] goes wrong at the wedding movie
you're like [ __ ] it come on nobody's
gonna die at this way that stupid
doesn't happen nobody died at our
wedding but three people got killed by
jet ski everything went wrong everything
and that fellas welcome no look at my
sister's wedding yeah uh my
brother-in-law's uncle had a heart
attack oh Jesus and the best man and the
other groomsmen it was the best man uhhh
his other really good friend and then me
and my brother right those two guys were
both firemen so soon as guy had a heart
attack they hopped like the the wedding
party table right ran over and like a
one of my family members is a nurse and
she's like sitting there going I think
we need to bubble but these guys come in
they go get him down rip his shirt open
one guy goes into compression the other
ones giving him mouth-to-mouth they're
like boom boom everyone's like watching
like holy [ __ ] this is intense I
remember i still have my champagne from
like the toast it just happened and i'm
just annealing wow this is crazy you
know I just just watching and then also
we any he comes back oh [ __ ] right
ambulant a bring them up someone's
getting orange juice or something huh oh
thank with someone to drive like if I
forgot me just died no boat no freezer
so the ambulance they came in they put
him on the stretcher and like they're
wheeling them out of the ball and take a
ball it's a big room they're wheeling
them out and everyone's kind of like
what do you do and I'm not kidding this
guy just went boom and thrill of thumb
up like he just got hit on the 20 yard
line it was Dennis bird it was a very
guy you know what would have been even
better if your sister and your brother
huh that was their entrance to their
first dance because you know everyone
goes like a wacky SH Maggie thing now so
that was there like why and they start
to like tango you know I mean like
they're like doing like the wacky dance
that I went to a wedding where that
happen where what so yeah okay so tell
us what your entrance was
oh no this was went wrong oh yeah okay
so first of all is an outdoor wedding
end of May in Los Angeles oh yeah it's
pretty hot no no we're storm of reading
here ready to do worst story you're with
us of the year a 12 that now too how old
do you think I 2008 Oh doesn't AOA yeah
so um we didn't think that it was gonna
rain because we did like the whole
Farmers Almanac I don't know we did I
some random times a year yeah end of May
in Los Angeles and you don't understand
it's true but gloom is different
Memorial Day Memorial days always whose
flowers bring me fight you know april
showers bring me an hour don't try to
don't try it no don't try to get all
like weather channel up in here as well
as ours called Sheila report yeah don't
try to be like a winner Roman I you ride
me the [ __ ] yeah yes so I with outdoor
wedding a wedding planner who was oh so
sweet and romantic and she was with this
boyfriend for five years as she was like
and we're gonna get married soon and
then in the middle of planning our
wedding they broke up and she just was
like [ __ ] love and everything was
[ __ ] to her after the head we're
like what do you think about these
tablecloths Oh what do I think I think
love is the worst that she would say
that yes she's like [ __ ] love and we're
like oh so the moth is that what you're
saying we should go baby a mom la taupe
no she hated everything we talked about
the minute they broke up like oh we
decided on this centerpiece oh really
we'll decide on maybe breaking up in a
couple years after he makes you promises
like she was worst the absolute worst
she turned into a demon and so we had to
contend with her then the the day of the
wedding there was the worst storm I've
ever experienced living in Los Angeles
it was like the year that all the
mudslides happened and I got up at five
o'clock Oh cheering it was so is 19 okay
and I got up that morning and I told my
husband right canceling it like I was
just in a [ __ ] day
oh yeah like words he's like oh let me
give it to you just every time she's in
a bad mood I got just get a [ __ ] ray
girl let's go I was like we're not
wearing those Jurassic Park yellow
ponchos and he's like don't worry it's
gonna clear up like he just was so calm
about it yeah exit the pool it was wait
where was it in LA Simi Valley Mountain
I likes yeah yeah stop in the Mona simi
valley tomorrow I'll Ronald Reagan
freeway so careful is crazy rains up in
they're gonna know two places yeah what
are you doing two places don't worry
okay well um since I've been named
dropping this whole time we had our
wedding where they did you ever watch
The Biggest Loser no oh this is not a
damn thing it's beautiful anyways a
ranch where they shot biggest loser whoo
so were we because we had to get a
ten-thousand-dollar tent at the last
minute day of damn but was it so wet
underneath the tent cuz it rained all
day they were they had like you know
they were mopping it and trying to get
this one do that looked like the guy
from my elementary school that one crazy
looking janitor you know when the kids
would vomit and he throw like sawdust
yeah she came out like trying to soak it
up with sawdust right like what are you
doing here when I'd fail oh yeah yeah
and so we got a tank I drop 10 G's on
the bill right then and i'm still paying
that [ __ ] tender still did it
rain though i was gonna say was there no
rain so it rained in the morning and I I
don't know what I just I got out of bed
and I've sloshed through the rain where
our ceremony was going to be an
interception so our reception is gonna
be when literally flop I was sloshing it
was so torrential if this Ross oh yeah
just rozz/landy right this way put a
slip and it's not right for the flower
girl just like
that was tight I thinking about a
wedding in her down I um I went down to
the logo there's like a ralphs down the
hill right so I go down to the ralphs I
was like I'm just gonna get a coffee I
just need to get out and this woman who
was sweet the cashier was like well
today is gonna suck not know it's my
wedding day was it the same lady that
looks like seriously the wedding planner
wedding planner no no it's nice little
Ralph's cashier lady that I went bought
balloons so people could find the venue
because it's like off a windy road so
I'm sitting there was like 30 balloons
in the worst in rock in st. like we know
in the rain is coming up like member
Forrest Gump was like the rain was like
sideways rain and like the rain was
coming up into my face now just because
it's the worst day I'm just picturing
like a little kid behind you with like a
tack like he's like copying the time I
get to the venue I typed the balloons
they get the tent the [ __ ] tent up
I'm $10,000 thousand-dollar tent luckily
$10,000 10,000 luckily did not rain
during the ceremony it did not it's what
then it cleared up so then you got
[ __ ] out of 10 grand just don't really
didn't need it still had a tent cleared
up um you take a tent down know what
fight with other 10,000 take it down I
mean look taking a harder put those up
in here the circus tent a hundred people
down fee yeah it was ugly as [ __ ] and
then it wasn't big enough to it blue
yeah cuz of the monster by Gavin no that
would be sick was about him right there
I'll be sick oh oh my god it was so ugly
and it was like flapping like they
didn't secure the side so then they
brought in these heaters that you must
heat like like a concert like an outdoor
Coachella concert because they were just
like oh you can smell the gas to run out
of gas
we're not nice Heat they weren't the
heaters they're like the at a fancy
restaurant oh my god they were like
industrial industrial thought they were
just ah so people's hair is kicking on
fire don't you within 30 feet stay
behind at yo hora we didn't order a big
enough one but they luckily had a side
temperatures wedding I've ever mrs.
flotations la Louve sides we pay for
brand for this I'm not kidding you I
forgot about much was it how much I
don't member the side 10 at that point I
blacked out Brody saving this whole side
to side too but the wedding made like a
leather bra not everybody could see like
it had it you gotta go down a hallway
wait a minute so not everyone could fit
in the big pencil the other side and I
tent via satellite like the TV's up
she's good Zack become director and it's
like when the when the teams like when
your team's playing away but they let
people come in the state yeah side Tenth
no side Tenth the people that were
seated in the side Tenth were pissed as
[ __ ] and you know what we were gonna see
I know where I stand this is that cake
platter back because I saw him to shred
Niall [ __ ] up wedding planner [ __ ] up
the entire seating so she put like
Soviets with like asians you don't
[ __ ] do that everyone knows that
that's wedding 101 she put like family
members that didn't even belong they
hate each other we took so much time you
know how much time it takes to plan like
the seating arrangement yeah when she
was like you know easy to say [ __ ] love
[ __ ] really tailing she did like bingo
she just picked him out of a bag she's
like all right we'll put this person at
this table she just [ __ ] us completely
so that was a message out so but was was
that configuration because of the tent
and everything or with that but we
wanted out of 10 everyone would have
been able to see this is that in the
barn she's on the bottom there was there
was a barn there by the way there was a
bar so uh then then things start to like
work out okay you know things were like
ok they're flowing smoothly it was nice
things were happening right the bands on
stage
um the the appetizers are coming out
because everything was on trays you know
all that and then head on head trays
stop the head I'm puddle I'm not kidding
you in like a movie that like the [ __ ]
up character in a movie that's just you
know always causing some sort of trouble
some catering chick it was slow motion
it was slow motion she took this big-ass
industrial plug and went to go home so
and it was slow motion like we were all
like oh cuz it was an outdoor wedding so
there's a generator that can't handle a
lot one shade lighter she yes she
plugged a coffee thing in some sort of
coffee slow motion she goes to plug it
in everything just goes boom come on
everything the band no music they
wouldn't play just give us a gun but me
at best the shame you know they hava
nagila just you stopped everything
stopped no band the food stopped cooking
they were vegan yeah that was just for
them stuff but in a vagabond one chick
who's stuck in the auxiliary dead I'll
take care of that jab did she [ __ ] us
she [ __ ] us the food stop cooking the
food stop cooking it for food move the
food front of the yellow thing yeah man
all of a sudden everyone's coming to us
cuz you know when you and my husband
works in television production I work in
television so we're like all right let's
divide and conquer so we go over here we
go over there we try to figure anything
out then all of a sudden your wedding
like you're producing your special yes
exactly the same thing are you producing
all of a sudden you know the food is
late now it's late everyone's like what
the [ __ ] going on Mike's mom obviously
look at her and Mike's Mike and I are
like your mom she's diabetic so now
she's like shaking she's like I gotta
get sushi
doesn't she doesn't know she died that a
loose woman Brad neuter no he's yet to
on the auxiliary tenant even aware hey
mom it's our anniversary an emergency my
diabetes too [ __ ] first and
diabetes is a [ __ ] there's no one there
to like give you like a brochure welcome
BTW i make it about her so we're like we
gotta get mike's mom some food she's
like shaking you know frothing at the
mouth yo J and we actually did have a
firefighter than two he do [ __ ] quick so
we're like hurry hurry so Mike's aunt
comes running as she's running to help
out Mike's mom she trips and falls come
on she just goes up so much she's down
she's down we're like in the mud no it's
grass you know still she's down so
larger ladies so now we're like oh I get
someone get a splint for aunt nilda so
int nil des down how old is she would
you say I don't know if these sixties
just old enough that when someone falls
you go concern yeah was she on the train
out with you guys no it's his aunt it's
isn't he has three key so his mom and
his aunt or basically town right down
just slight bit of a difference I look
at my wedding planner like do some all
she's like oh you something I'll show
you what I'm [ __ ] I'm gonna do right
now that's what it sounds like well if
everyone was concerned and everyone
stopped everything and it was like just
turned into something that you just your
nightmares nightmares all da all my
picture is the aunt falling so
everyone's paying attention and cuts of
Mike's mom like there's like one piece
of candy in the middle table just trying
to get it looks just freaking out this
little guy that got me into survival
time no it's very good don't pay
attention
oh my god it was so awful it sounds
fantastic but my mom got drunk and she
jumped naked into the pool name is that
in her thank you have you ever seen her
do anything she threw [ __ ] at someone
leave in Russia but there was ever
symbolic my mom likes to be naked she'll
she'll go to some nudist colonies she's
all about oh she does news call me yeah
yeah there's a place for real in
Northern California I think it might
have just closed which I can't believe
they just came around to like maybe we
should close this [ __ ] down nudists
calling is very popular it's called
Wilbur spring ways your dad into nudity
well they're divorced uh-huh but just
couldn't just couldn't take it she like
you guys guess what I saw this weekend
he's into very tight small underwear so
it's almost like being nude right like
he walks around the house basically in
like tidy just Jim Palmer speedo no no
they they are like hi like to go up high
remember like in the 80s went home kinis
yeah yeah I know what you're talking hi
here's nice hips gives nice hips my
buddy's dad will do that around his
granddaughter so they live with him and
walk around his toys and they're like
weird that put clothes on it as my house
and he does it just a freaking annoy
everybody yeah yeah no that's damn I dad
like his bikini man underwear look like
you know Borat's bikini yeah but how
went over his shoulders my dad's just
you know they just stopped at the waist
but that's what they look like just real
high and tight real high and tight yeah
that's it that's what I grew up with so
I'm comfortable with with my father's
junk probably too comfortable yeah
probably a little too comfortable so
after that man when shaken in the pool
is anyone else in the pool I think this
guy she was you did your date Hannah
ball him behind her and that was in the
in those trunks and blacks live over
there after old trick no TV in there now
everyone said Jim Palmer speedos is
jockeys stayed far stay far how deep
into the wedding was it was like the
wedding pretty much over or people like
sleet and cake wedding was over the
morning it started raining he it was
over I'll show you as a picture after
the podcast of us in the tent I'll show
you it's true it's the real deal so the
reason I say this bring it up is because
those types of things no one like
everyone else around was like it's fine
they don't know really what's going on
it's like the entire wedding knew about
Mike's mom or I mean they they knew like
something was up like all the foods kind
of late and the band stop playing like
they knew but everyone's like it was
still really fun it was to have fun
because we're Russians and we packed the
bar and every table had five different
bottles of alcohol on every single table
plus with an open bar so there was
plenty to drink and there was still like
food around and things like that but
nobody really knew mom lost a leg Mike's
mom oh you'll need those three toes
wasted but that's what I mean later
Mike's mom has diabetes she does does
now she doesn't ya know the special was
the same kind of thing like things were
going wrong no one else knew right like
swing when you guys a [ __ ] all on
yourself exactly and I'm pregnant me
like hey gang only crowdfunded you guys
did crowd for thank you so much that ten
dollars took us over we got craft
service for that Bank you look we did
you wanna make so much mom had some
candy bars but like things aren't wrong
like no one else knew but certain people
knew and it's just one of those things
where like why the [ __ ] is this
happening why can't it just goes
smoothly for example um uh the lights
were not what I expected so I walked out
on stage and that my director and I week
had a little miscommunication they were
much brighter than I expected you know
when you go out and you're like okay
it's gonna be what it was during the
tech we liked a little rehearsal you
know a little villain I feel like
they're the lite version of the heaters
at your wedding right well that's that's
the next thing the next thing so the
lighting that we chose we chose lighting
behind me okay park hands behind me and
then in front had no idea that it was
going to be a hundred and fifty degrees
so the minute I stepped out on stage I
immediately am drenched in sweat jess
was coming out of your entire bum
everywhere completely so I'm sweating
profusely and I'm pissing myself and the
lights and I'm wearing a jacket and then
when you're pregnant you're hot anyway
so I am come I'm drenched immediately
and I'm a Soviet so just the pits just
like you like when so what you bite into
like a star Burt you know like it's a
push like the juice came out just the
first two seconds so you're like trying
to get you know warm up the crowd a
little bit with the first few jokes but
I'm immediately drenched and I saw the
audience and I didn't want to see the
audience and they were like chicks you
just wanted to see light I just wanted
to see a couple people in the first few
rows you know how you like I like it
pitch black I really love it just like
dark dark dark dark dark or so yeah not
bright bright lights so you can't see
like
do you know I mean but I mean usually
the bride of the light the less you can
see people in the audience is a nice
mixture of I like to do crowd work which
I did do crowd work on my special looks
i like to do that but I I don't want to
see it was it was like I'm onstage in
your route in your studio right now and
then you see how bright your neon
fluorescent lights are yeah it was like
that yeah like around the perimeter of
the room um my director explained it
goes look we need it because we're gonna
we're gonna do we're gonna show the
audience members you know I mean we're
gonna show but it just threw me off
immediately and I saw these chicks that
were fans awesome scene is there cuttin
audience member likes these women that
were very sweet and they were fans and
we packed the place which was nice so
we're here add the coach house in Orange
County hooker and it seats like 500 and
so they were there with the best of
intentions but they were so excited that
they got out of their seats and started
taking selfies so with during the
filming during the taping they were
taking [ __ ] selfies out of excitement
oh thanks during my yeah yes Sebastian
during the taping so I'm looking at this
and I'm like just stay in the zone just
stay in the zone like the whole time
just stay in the zone you're sweating
okaying it gets better you're you're
noticing this shit's going on it gets
better I'm looking at the crowd because
I know I want to talk to the crowd so
I'm checking everybody out saying hello
I look over there's a nice woman there
holding a baby come on baby not just
like a newborn an 18 month old baby in
the front row how did you get there ok
who's screaming outside they're a nice
family what hurts unfair I mean that the
father's there the white with the what
looking though the mothers there they're
nice black family that I asked my
producers why did you let a baby in the
front and then she's like oh you haven't
tell the black people to get into the
back of the room xiamen to say tell the
black people go get in the back of the
room yeah
oh you tell the people with the baby
yeah I know need heartless but it's
orange county and black people came out
and I'm excited and so uh okay babies
anyone's endeavor baby said you want to
sit down big thing by my cv fun to your
teeny got a mazda brawny fuzzy glass
t-shirt on look at he's a fan no Joanna
crabmeat now i'm doing my jokes and in
between setups the baby's crying oh my
god that's happening yes ah how many did
you tape 1 CH 01 Wow but when I did a
show time special I only did one yeah i
know but i'm still I'm just did you have
a baby crying on the show times I did
not know I did not I did not baby was
behaved oh my god and so it just all
these things they were just kind of one
after the other you comment on the baby
crying of course I did of course of
course I did I said um I I forgot what I
ripped something like you know you guys
are [ __ ] idiots or something funnier
than that but I I had to I had to
comment on that but I just started to I
felt beaten down at this point my kids
are in the car okay its my special my
kids are out in the car right now you
know that kid is two and a half years
old right now and he's here right now
baby wear sarees that race you've been
in the back we just need to bring it
down if you look closely you will see
it's a little girl and she has those
little pom-pom um runs late oh my god so
cute is she laughing matter she's like I
mean she was heading on a site she ought
she was heckling she was crying you do
see and I think we cut around it but
like I they did get up and leave
eventually when I said with a flare you
do night with the rest here's good Oh
I I mean it was just one thing so yeah I
had to beat him up to get up the file a
bit I think she's talking to us so you
say by else'll the baby the baby yeah
I'll be honest if that was me because
this is what I cuz I like seeing the
crowd too i love a lit room i love
seeing everywhere is dimly lit i'll see
you i love see everybody and what my
problem used to be it's not so much
anymore but I still kind of do it
sometimes is I'd look for people who
aren't laughing and then I go at them
you know I mean oh no I got one of those
okay but if I kept seeing a baby like
condoms that babies tell you and I just
like keep checking in on the bay because
and then I wouldn't be present with my
material you know yeah and you're
urinating a long time and I'm sweating
profusely and there's a guy now Orange
County is you know they have this older
crowd a little bit older crowd um and I
was targeting families I was targeting
you know in my crowdfunding and all the
press I was like it's Mother's Day come
out for Mother's Day cuz we shocked you
know Sunday night mother's day this is a
great event that was that didn't know
that it was gonna be like grandmother's
day so there's this old ass dude always
[ __ ] huge he's enormous and he's his
head is like three people above
everybody else is at and it's it's like
eraser shaped it wasn't like an or
monster human yes it wasn't normal human
it was just a rectangle that just stuck
out like a thumb just a thumb in a sea
of hands just like this big old white
thump and he's not laughing at anything
and then halfway through it so I had one
camera that was because it be camera
just technical be camera right that
caught the audience over my shoulder
kind of and the entire time he's right
there the entire time man asleep come on
Harley or having a stroke or having the
first day 2 diabetes yeah maybe his day
we're gonna save you a lot of day once
oh my god oh why is this happiness and
amidst all that somehow we still managed
to pull out a [ __ ] kick-ass awesome
special that's
with all that craziness that's what I
told my husband I'm like with all the
craziness of our wedding but it somehow
we're still married with two kids yeah
it sounds like this is what you feed off
of I survived gaiser I don't think I
seek there are people that seek out
drama right I don't seek it out I like
drama free life I like just being chill
and things just happening organically
like I'm very I'm very yoga you always
hide rock me that way yeah yeah I do not
seek out craziness but somehow it is put
upon me and I have to deal with it and
and remain graceful somehow I don't know
maybe it's from being beaten as a child
so many times but just I'm like I'll get
through this I'll live through this I'll
survive this beating society is beating
me hahaha societal beatdowns you but
it's still it's still it still worked
it's still really good i'm very proud of
it well congratulations on it now
everybody should watch it i'm now when I
can't wait to see because I'm gonna look
all your Easter eggs drop those guys
sleeping down for a little black baby
baby over there came out of the bathroom
sure there's more I'm sure there's more
I'm just blocking it out as a sweat I'm
gonna see you'll see the sweater
unfortunately although my makeup lady
Jamie Stevens shout out to you she's
amazing not she amazed he's here right
he's here right up your brush come on up
sorry can get you the budget girl that's
never gonna get old ever ever ever ever
not awesome yeah zune did though what
else we got on there well first of all
congratulations as I said and second of
all we're glad you're here because
before as we sat down you said you
almost died and i'm assuming i no no i
said murder what didn't i say murder i
almost got my oh no oh no no it's
different than dying word yeah yeah
always murdered i mean i don't mean to
be laughing at that laughing it murder
can be funny uh well I'm just laughing
that you're saying now that's a way
different you're right i'm sorry i might
have said it i almost died because i
almost got murdered is what i was trying
to say man so I am I lived in London
when I was 20 I decided
laughs all right you know when when
normal kids do like a year abroad and
they get it all organized through their
school and they take a year abroad and
it's all you know everyone has okayed it
with their professors and they're gonna
get an exchange no Kyra does things her
own way and I barely I told my parents
to you with having babies the specials
the wedding You certainly have done
things there is one advantage to having
immigrant parents you can just tell them
[ __ ] anything and they're just like
okay that sounds good if if if
government is okay with it I say yes to
you so I told my parents I was taking a
year i was going to hear abroad
meanwhile no school I just went to
London oh you just went to go tween
junior and senior year of college I just
[ __ ] let you took one year off of
school yes they caught on halfway
through they were like you think you can
lie to me I were cast by Jill yeah for
seven months I did right I did I lied to
everybody working so i went to move to
london and i did join this like kind of
like a program but it wasn't the school
abroad it just was this [ __ ] up like
everybody live in a house and I none of
us had money zero money we were all just
scavengers like I live like a raccoon
for me just eating garbage cans but I
got jobs his little jobs in theaters
right so I was a theater major so I
thought I'll get a job in theatre I did
everything like backwards like and then
I'll go back to my college and tell them
this is my experience can I get credit
for us give me twenty six credits yeah I
was a raccoon in London can I get some
credits for that so I worked in this
theater where I was an electrician
because I lied to them so i told them
that i could do could you have to hang
lights when you're a theater major in
college they make you hang lights and
I've done that for your special I
thought I did I until I produce okay
well clearly you didn't cuz you're upset
with the life you could have rigged it
I'm saying I I went to this theater it's
in the West End of London and it's it's
theatre row it's like where the gielgud
theatre is and it's we're all like the
big theatre houses where you go to see
Phantom of the Opera and all that right
and I told them that I was
electrician and they they were like
we're not going to pay you and I was
like perfect so I was working for free
and they caught on that I was an idiot
completely lied um but I was again doing
this like retroactive student credit so
that I was making up on my own and I
want it to work and I wanted to like get
experience so they would [ __ ] with me
every day they would Hayes be in some
sort of way every day sometimes it was
really benign stuff like they would send
me to the hardware store and they say go
to the hardware store and pick up some
spirit level fluid with an assortment of
bubbles oh yeah which doesn't this
doesn't know you don't get spirit
knowing if you crack your your level or
it's done no one's refilling their
spirit but I'm an idiot so I go to the
hardware store up the street and I ask
for spirit level fluid with an
assortment of bubbles and everybody
they're [ __ ] laughs their asses off
and then I hang my head low and walk
back down to the theater like [ __ ] that
got me again this happened every day
every day they would send me someplace
that go go up and get the sky hook out
of the closet skyhook dreams up there
laughing so they have different words
for cigarettes you know they call him
[ __ ] so like all right they have a
different word for something I was like
I'll go find a skyhook there's no
[ __ ] thing is there's such thing so
every day they would they would lock me
in a closet one of the closets was full
of rats these are theaters from the from
the 12th century Shakespeare at the
shakespeare like in Shakespeare rats
there are they like to be or not to be
they squeaked in iambic pentameter and
you know they were [ __ ] up rats too
they weren't normal American rats that
you're like all right girl where's gotta
pack I got diabetes I got rapid diabetes
and I was in this closet once for maybe
four hours whoa locked come on with rats
with rats no lights I didn't know what
the lights off I was wrong I was like I
was like Anne Frank all over you I'm
like
just like so uh [ __ ] to me all the
time so this is the day they almost
murdered me if you look up in when
you're in a beautiful old eat I'm
theater you're in the let's say near the
orchestra pit right you look up and
you'll see the huge enormous ornate
chandelier that they have right it's
it's they're absolutely magnificent if
you ever see them up close which I had
to because I had to clean them so what
they do is they pull them up very slowly
like on a chain they cry I love them
like who's gonna clear the chandelier
the electrician yeah your electrician
that's what they call me the yang Gor so
they pulled up the show's day or the day
to clean the chandelier or some [ __ ]
enter they pull it up and it's uh it
lives in this thing called the void
that's what they call it because it's
not really a room there's no real floor
it's it's just made out of plaster
there's nothing but you have to get to
the chandelier right so it's made out of
nothing except for you know something
like your kid makes at school like a
project you know I mean like some most
papers yeah newspapers our water and our
paper mache thank you so um so we go up
to the void and this one dude that hated
me the most took me up there right and
he goes all right like I don't I'm gonna
try to do is [ __ ] accent I always
sound like you know hello Mary Poppins
like I can't if I can do it but he's
like what you're gonna do is you're
gonna walk out on this beam on this
plank I go ok so there's like a harness
or something he goes no no you just walk
out how high up is it no you're at the
top of the ok yes I mean we've had in 40
feet 50 feet 150 ok oh this is a huge
theater look an enormous the I'm
honestly maybe 200 I don't even know hi
up its high it's extremely high yeah and
this room that the chandelier gets
lifted up into is you know its beams so
you're walking on be
seems like you would when our house is
being built you know it's just those
construction workers in New York like in
the yeah exactly that no harness no
nothing and you have to just like hold
yourself with the beam on top right so
you're just like scurrying over and the
lights are on so I kind of like see what
I'm doing and then he I hear him walking
behind me right so he's like walking and
I'm like wait how do I hear footsteps
there's no floor right huh I don't want
to turn around cuz I'm on this beam and
I kind of crank my neck ever so slightly
so I don't lose my balance he's off of
his beam I thought he was gonna do the
work and I'm just gonna like help him or
your hand some [ __ ] to him he's on the
floor part safety and he takes again
it's just so comical like in a cartoon
like in a Bugs Bunny cartoon this big
ass switch you know those big switch
yeah he just goes to handy you later he
like Josh and turns off all the lights
come on all the lights and I can't see
anything and so I'm like what's
happening guys what's going on there's
no net under use your no harness the big
top well there I'll be that high up you
thinking later when I safety net there's
this void but the void is nothing it's
not gonna hold any weight it's plaster
it's not like you can put any weight on
it and so you're standing on a small
plank holding over your healthy behavior
your head and not know another wooden
beam oh okay right and I'm standing
there and he's like Oy don't move if you
do like [ __ ] pirates the caribbean if
you do you're a goner that's what he
says to me Brandon leaves and then he
leaves he takes off so I'm standing
there and I'm like this this is just a
joke like they normally do okay guys you
gotta hold your hands above your head
for like yeah I'm on it you're gonna
that's gonna hurt well God's best that's
what's throw that's where the story
comes in okay so I have one hand now
right cuz I'm letting it all out up
there at this point [ __ ]
no so I um I'm standing there for so
long that I'm like well maybe happen
this is how stupid I was I was 20 I was
an idiot I was like well maybe I can
crouch down and sit on this or like hug
it with my body if they they're gonna
leave you here for a really long time
right so I'm thinking of myself and I'm
calling out to them like hey guys like
[ __ ] Luke Skywalker out later cut a
fan totally bad I'm like waiting for the
Millennium Falcon across a me and I'm
just like okay guys it's funny like I
get it and I'm thinking like okay and
I'm literally like hahaha just like the
spirit level fluid good one guys I'm
talking to no one no one is there what
time of day is this is the middle of a
day but it's so dark cuz they turned off
all the lights yeah it's completely dark
I can't see anything which I would have
loved for my special yeah I should I
should have told them like give me void
of the void in the theater lights so I'm
standing there and I start to have a
mental breakdown I start to go over
every choice that I made to get to this
place like why did I lie to my parents
why am I here i'm living like a raccoon
I'm scavenger for food I and I and again
my I'm losing blood like you know blood
is like leaving my hands so I'm starting
to shake so I start putting one hand
down holding the other hand and I hear I
hear something behind me and like please
tell me you're here to help me right and
I hear something I don't want to turn
around I don't see anything anyway but I
don't want to turn around because I'm
just so scared and I'm like I don't know
who you are I'm just like talking to the
darkness hahaha I just I'm sorry I don't
know what I did to piss you off but I'm
sorry I don't want to upset you guys if
you want I'll leave today I'll quit cuz
they had asked me to quit so many times
I was good I wouldn't and they weren't
being me so I was just like they were
like uh we can't like just fire you we
don't pay so my legs start to go right
so now my legs are shaking right
and I was like my legs are shaking I
need help right I hear hear like someone
breathing I just here like this this is
giving anxiety me too I can't be abyss
below you right now I I can only laugh
about it now I at the time I thought
well this is where I die this is where I
[ __ ] die and honestly they could make
any of this look like an accident I mean
this is she said she was electrician she
don't know what the [ __ ] she's done he
wandered up there and why did I lie why
am I here um my legs are starting to
shake right so so I go okay I'm just
gonna let go and I thought I'll just
like slowly crouch if I can hold how why
do you think this beam is I do my 40
what's a two-by-four that's ready to buy
you a four by four maybe no no it's a
two by four I know my dad's in whole
contract yeah he builds houses it's what
you it's like you're your box were there
that then yeah it that's two by four
right like that yeah don't look it's a
beam that you see when people are just
starting to build a house so because
they're there can't be much weight
because this thing again is made out of
nothing so there can't be any weight in
and around it because it'll crumble you
know what I mean so um so I start to
shake right so I'm I'm like reaching up
to touch the beam on top right as I'm
trying to also reach talk about a great
yoga move by the way I got an amazing
stretch I'm trying to also see if I can
reach the beam that I'm standing on so
make the transition quickly oh and I
can't I can't do it I can't do it and I
again I feel something or someone behind
me and I go if there if you're here I'm
just begging you just turn on the lights
you don't have to even help me just how
long at this point you up there hour
maybe an hour maybe an hour yeah my legs
are completely noodles noodles I can't
feel them right because I'm balancing
and by the way I could have used a snack
I couldn't use a snack i'll be honest
because look at Little Caesar kicking it
Mackey so um I feel the beam have a
little bit
pressure on it so I was like oh this is
a good thing right like someone's here
to help me and I go okay I know
someone's here now why aren't you saying
anything you can at least talk to me and
are you crying at all I'm pretty comfy
pretty can be never I'm pretty much on
the verge but again I know that if I
show them a lot of weakness the weakness
is what got me here in the first place
because they knew I was a pushover very
vulnerable a [ __ ] American who loves
to like hey everybody let's have some
crumpets like I was like you know yeah
just wanted to I'm a people pleaser to
begin with so um I thought okay
someone's here to help right I feel wait
on the beam on top as well so they're
also balancing so someone is here thank
God I'm like oh thank you so much I
don't know who you are but thank you i
start naming all the names mike is this
will will is that you I always knew I
who had my back will no answer ah this
is Jamie good job Jamie thanks dude I
appreciate it no answer and like okay
like I'm running out of people right I'm
going through like five six people that
work in the department with me um then
again no answer there's jumping and
shaking no well it's dark well it's dark
Dave night vision god I [ __ ] lost my
[ __ ] I was like you're gonna kill me I
started screaming I was like I start I
was so I was 20 so so overly dramatic I
was like there will be blood on your
hands been on the floor you don't be
Lady Capulet and then I feel another
jump and they're trying to murder me
this is not murder like [ __ ] with me
is one thing this is immense maybe
second or third you know like turning
off the lights is like one thing but now
you're like trying to make me fall you
did you gonna throw in your voice out of
me like and they're just wing graphite
like oh
okay so I decide after an hour I don't
know why I didn't do this sooner this is
I'm I put a lot of the fault on me too
I'm like why am I not just shuffling
backwards yeah right so I'm like I'll
just shuffle backwards because I know
where I came from right so I start
shuffling backwards so I'm going slowly
and I hear like oh [ __ ] like I hear I
hear people now I'm like [ __ ] there's
more than one person here Wow Gary
engine could NT yeah I start going
backwards from where I came from really
slowly and I'm like why the [ __ ] did I
do this to begin with because I had
faith in them that maybe they would turn
on the lights so I'm really slowly I'm
working backwards um [ __ ] up my hands
by the way just like splinters every
time I work bag which is like I had
company were completely red and purple
yeah yeah and so I'm working backwards
and I hear people now I'm like there's
not just one person so I was like I
[ __ ] hear you [ __ ] and I
turned on a dime I was like you
[ __ ] I swear to God if I find
out who did this and I turn into this
evil person so now I'm like going from
people pleaser to like gay guys I get it
was a joke you guys are real funny to
like I will fight I will find where
every single one of you [ __ ]
lives I swear to God and by the way
Tommy you [ __ ] I know you've
been [ __ ] stealing yeah [ __ ]
watching your ass and I shush hey buddy
out one after the other and I go oh and
rear decaf yeah and I go oh and Rick
when I see your girlfriend I'll happen
to accidentally mention how you get hand
jobs from the Stewart like the the
hostess that seems people right cuz he
was getting hand jobs from the girls at
seat people and so all of a sudden I
hear like I spent like murmurs and [ __ ]
so I turned on them and I start calling
all of them out right and then
we better kill this next thing I know I
feel a hand on my shoulder a hand right
so I grabbed it I'm like yeah I grabbed
him so i'll animate he falls down what
yes he fell and I had to grab him and I
[ __ ] grabbed his torso and the lights
went on immediately they were like [ __ ]
it's Rick and because it was Rick I
pissed off Rick's that's telling this
girl friend he's giving hand jobs to the
chicks so I the lights go on and I
grabbed Rick and I go hands can be good
for something else too Rick I just saved
you so Rick is not i mean like we
weren't I'd shuffled back so close that
we were next to the wall like where the
floor was but Rick's face looked at me
and I looked at him and I go yeah tables
are turned I turned into a psychopath
carrier manga she said yeah they know
you're not a guy here you know you're
busted so these [ __ ] these limey
bastards tried to kill me and almost got
one of their own and I saved him and I
was like oh he goes oh he go oh my god I
turned into member that character um
funny bunny or funny honey and who's the
chick uh [ __ ] that's Quinn Tarantino
movie the best pulp fiction Jesus when
when they are when they're robbing the
diner he's like you can mean funny be
cool yeah something like they're like be
cool be cool be cool I lost my [ __ ] had
never seen this side of me because I was
20 I didn't have this really next week
they had our seating people heads out
for everybody was all day no no got
promoted that electric I stayed I stayed
did you win them over like do they like
nasty first of all did let me tell you
what wins British people over when you
when you call them on their [ __ ]
I did not know this I didn't know when
they call you a fat cow and you go hon
come on guys let's get a sandwich
they're like [ __ ] her [ __ ] her you know
they were they they changed like first
of all I had a laundry list I had known
these [ __ ] for months so I knew
every [ __ ] like when they when they
took breaks when they weren't supposed
to they were getting high they were
getting drunk one guy was stealing the
guys getting hand jobs like I had a
laundry list on them I I have to ask
this Rick was coming out to do what I
don't know that's what I want to know
I'm sitting here thinking about that
like wait a second that dude came out it
was the one you were calling out for
getting hand job yeah and came out and
put his hand physically hardly to lead
me out but leave you out like Florida or
back I think to take me in but I don't
understand like how is that funny god
forbid something really did happen get
all those I don't yeah I think they were
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] let's get her
husband they turn on the lights there
were like five six people all the people
that worked in electrics they call it
electrics in the UK they were all there
yeah they were all there to witness what
I don't get it I just don't get it like
I am so the opposite person in my nature
in my core if I was on that team of
people I would have never even let it
happen once not once I would never yeah
whatever people anybody get hazed ever I
just can't I just they hazed me they
that's what no that's that is almost
killing that is beyond a murder murder
that's what way beyond anything and I
just don't I'll never understand that I
look at it now I can laugh and we can
joke about it but at the time I was you
know was just so young I was still
learning like what friendships were and
what relationships were and business and
how to conduct yourself this is how i
was introduced to the world I don't know
as a parent now it really [ __ ] with me
now if that I just I don't know that was
my kid I would I would I would kill some
oh yeah i would first kill Rick except
my mother [ __ ] I know that killed my
daughter for lying me bug dude semester
abroad can you mouth classes going I
almost
yeah that's [ __ ] up yeah I've crazy
anxiety here and that just being
visually up there on the beam yeah it's
so [ __ ] hot you know what I never
really had um I don't I never really had
a fear of heights but for a while after
that I did it [ __ ] with me oh man I
would for the rest of my life I I have a
fear of chandeliers British people I
can't get near paper mache right now um
yeah so that's that's that story that's
a great story uh there are a couple more
I'd like to ask you about you thought
you said you were accidentally in a
threesome actually we're like don't say
anything else for uh for us please how
does that include your brother's picture
oh no how does a separate a separate
occasion how does an accidental
threesome Abbott all right so I went to
school in San Diego San Diego State
right after I graduated move up here a
friend of mine was getting married and
she said come on down to San Diego get
married ah do you only good tent people
so I again I was very young and I didn't
plan very well and I just like threw on
my dress I was gonna wear for the
wedding drove down to San Diego sure
okay you know anything i just might plan
on staying the night ok ok ok Jay Larson
ok you're a planner well no I mean but
I'm not got it I was an idiot just out
of college uh didn't even think that
maybe I don't want to do it for that
year english not gonna give me total
credits other they made me do an extra
year of college by the way i graduated
here late it's totally fine it was worth
it um so I went down to San Diego went
to the wedding didn't even think that
maybe I might want to have a drink and
not drive two hours home didn't plan
didn't get a hotel room first of all
honest let's be honest I don't have
money for a hotel room I know the deal
but I just didn't even think like maybe
talk to one of my
old college friends can I crash with you
guys didn't matter i knew a lot of
people there a lot of college people and
they said look we're all gonna crash
there's like 10 of us that are gonna
crash in one hotel room there's two
queen beds as a pull-out couch whatever
find a space piece of floor we'll figure
it out I was like cool thank you right
so um I'm already in my pajamas that
dress was my pajamas overall slap in it
so um you know for me one drink is
enough like it is more than a really one
such a lightweight and I am not really a
drink or so I'm not about getting like
[ __ ] up I'm just about like you know
like I feel silly right like that's
enough for me so everyone else though
they were do they were crazy I
understand people they were like not
only doing like just you're smoking out
and ayahuasca and you don't mean like
everyone's doing like dropping acid like
what are you dropping us it's a woman
what are you doing from the chana put
five balls of booze on every table her
way yeah well because I was raised right
yeah so everyone's [ __ ] up everybody's
[ __ ] up and there was this dude um
Rick right another Rick another rig
another Rick uh that I had always had a
crush on always like oh so cute right he
was at the wedding he was single I was
single bless you um and he was like not
be not into me at all because there are
certain guys especially in san diego
state that are just you got to be blonde
and tan and a volleyball player and I
was I'm the complete opposite I'm like
sweaty it's sappy you're really just
smelled like piss and you just never
been to homeless chick over never into
me and tips melam was a lot and and I
just was always kind of like I NM and
stuff right from at the wedding and
everyone's in the hotel room people
still partying people going crazy slowly
people are passing out come people took
this bad Kyle people just found a corner
pull out
ouch but I was excited cuz i found a
little slice on this bed that I was like
yes I don't have to sleep on the floor
right I'm already winning I'm so winning
right now so I fall asleep rick is next
to me actually right I know I know it's
exciting and this other like hot hot
chick just like so smoking hot just like
her whole body you know is hairless you
know that kind of hot and meanwhile Here
I am just like America you know I'm just
so the opposite anyway so she's on my
right he's on my left so everyone's
passed out four in the morning or
something crazy middle the night right
there should be nothing happening except
for snoring but all of a sudden I feel
like a hand just like smack me on the
face you know like like a hand coming
through dirt in a cemetery is alive
right he just comes out and starts
pawing me I was like what the [ __ ] is
happening right now so I look over and
I'm like this Rick and his hands just
like again with you just yelling name
haha oh you're is this rick is that you
you have you had a trick but Teddy's her
right he's like reaching over right I
was like wait a second is he tryna just
trying to hook up with me this is weird
he's on 15 Jager shots right away I knew
the assets kick it and viagra your dick
is not a sedan [ __ ] no dicks not working
they were all so [ __ ] up in this hot
chick next to me is half naked just I
don't know just titties always see it I
look over at her I'm like are you seeing
her she brought less than I I'm seeing
that Rick is do like I looked over to
see she's awake like is this gonna
happens it's gonna be weird right and I
just see titties just there's like a
nipple like right next to me I guess
tell me a secret for now bowling right
in my face and look up what is going on
I think it's red out of nowhere like
they had choreographed it her hand comes
up
and start spawn at me just like what
what's what is happening right now first
of all am I in them am I on the way here
of these general right you know so now
I'm like oh they want to hook up with
each other and I'm in the way ladies are
bridging them but I don't have a Cox I
can't cock-block them but I don't I'm
blocking him and I'm not into whatever's
happening because I'm just not that's
not my style like I'm not gonna do
anything with all these people in the
room first of all and she her clothes
aren't just like literally disintegrated
like they just like a harry potter like
spell just like they just like you know
gone i was like what when did that
happen he comes to he all of a sudden
has a second wind I don't know what's
happening but slick rick is now slick
dick because his haha his penis is out
yeah his penis wait how just keeping
quiet and has anyone saying anything no
is ESPN on but there's tons of people
just the people everyone's passed out
everyone's passed out drunk that for
once in a thriller video the real one I
hope has his hands now rick has his
hands all over me all over blondie just
all just everywhere there's hands just
hands and I'm just like I don't
understand it am i I'm so naive I'm
really bricks like your mom was cool I'm
just like what's a and he's so [ __ ] up
that he can barely kind of like he kind
of just like lick the side of my face
right so I was like oh this is gonna be
terrible yeah I got a thing for this guy
for so long and then I looked down his
pants are off and his hands are all over
and the blondes hands are all over and
it's like where's her head as she is
anyone kissing a word is like they just
like kind of like half asleep do they
know they're doing asleep ok he's
licking me
on my face who [ __ ] mummies hit it
looked like someone like maybe me
potentially falling slow-motion off of a
building there's just like hands and
legs like a turtle stuck on its back
just like a hands and legs like they're
trying to get stuff going but they're so
drunk and tired that they can't so I
notice I looked down I see his junk and
I'm like oh man oh really I've had a
crush on you for so long and this is
small dick Rick small dick Rick so sad
right so um he kind of starts to try to
kind of roll over on top of me right and
she notices there's some action
happening so she's awake and so she's
kind of grabbing there but they're both
kind of trying to undress me but i got
like zippers and buttons and you know to
me like I'm like all locked in like you
I gotta get a Makita to get me out of
this dress and I'm not into it I'm kind
of looking at them and when a sober
person is watching too drunk people
trying to get things hot and heavy it's
it's almost like when you watch your
two-year-old you know what I mean try to
like get like do something grown-up you
know I mean like oh you're gonna I'm
gonna watch you put your shoes on like
this is gonna be fun you know they like
they're starting they're starting to
grope each other so I figure I don't
want to be in the middle of this right
shimming out of that like you know like
you're on that [ __ ] to bum nope nope
nope nope hmm I help them I took now
there's like but like we're just the
three of our bodies are kind of like one
body right so I took her hand and put it
under his nuts and I start stroking like
I'm using her hand like an improv games
you are serious right now yes you know
like there's an improv game where
they're like phrase yeah and someone
comes behind you and then you're like
just a puppet puppet and they just have
to like control your body so I'm
stroking his nuts with her hand thinking
by the way that they're gonna pass out
any second he is into it horsey cuz he's
getting a smartie oh yeah and his hand
is kind of like up up my skirt a little
bit but I was like
no no no right so I like kind of like
I'm trying to be coy so I take his hand
and I just like shove it inside her I'm
not kidding I am the puppet mess Master
so i gave a talk on the puppet master
and so she's on top of me he's on top of
me they're kind of like kids seem but
also like pawing at me like a puppy you
don't mean just like pawing at me and so
I'm just like trying to get these two
together like I'm offering up her
genitals to his shadows like ah and I'm
trying to like get them like smashing
them together like just trying to make
something happen for them because I've
again I'm a people pleaser sure and I
want them to have a good time and it
never happened for poor Rick for small
dick Rick his penis just never it wasn't
up for the challenge it wasn't it was
not so they kind of smushed each other
and they kind of like dry humped me they
thought I think in their minds they were
like this is the hottest threesome of
every animal they need a juris you were
the missing piece I get yeah I guess I
guess so but I was more like furniture
like they were just driving her I were
using me like just an ottoman yeah but
they were they were doing something but
they never fully clock I I wanted them
to climax I wanted them so bad but I was
really cheering for them yeah I'm not
kidding when I say I had his hand my
hand is touching his hand as its inside
of her just trying my best to do what I
think I like I try to the movements yeah
like I'm like working the front working
the back was there what happened like
the next day then we're gonna like
brunch or something oh I got out of
there first thing in the morning you're
the first one oh are you [ __ ] kidding
me I couldn't look at them and one of
them's following me on Facebook I can't
oh really oh my god I can't no I can't
look at you anyway I mean imagine god
forbid the three of us had a threesome
right now God forgot forgot for beans
I couldn't could you look me in the eyes
afterwards oh yeah yeah i have taught to
have a bride no I hat down all the time
but I don't know I consider that my
first threesome cuz it was accident it
wasn't supposed to happen I mean that's
technically three something right yes I
would I consider it yeah i'm a bad girl
naughty i'm a naughty girl well i gotta
tell you we're at that time but my god
did we climax yeah we sure as [ __ ] did
this has been so much fun laadli i'm so
[ __ ] hard thank you sigh hope the
special is just as good as this yeah it
yes I've peed a little bit more now yeah
there's a guy sleeping outside right not
to so will you please one more time tell
them about the special where it'll be
when all that stuff may second 2016 in
case you're listening to this in case
you have a DeLorean and you went back in
time on amazon it's called you did this
to me it's my one hour special a shot at
seven months pregnant and you can also
find on itunes google play do you guys
look at google play for stuff I don't
know I'd even know where I'm frantic
then go to Google Play go listen to the
cat crap face and then go look at my
special you do this to me and I'm sure
you're gonna be tweeting it out on
Twitter and all that absolutely at kier
comedies my Twitter excellent excellent
always always a pleasure thanks for
having me on as always Jay Larson calm
be calm Jay Larson comedy across all
social media Ryan Sickler calm Ryan
Sickler on social media will talk y'all
next TV